okay guys do we have another call this
is the last call for today the number is
always 617 830 for 750 who am I talking
to where you calling from hi I'm calling
from troy ohio very cool what can we
what's your name and what can we do for
you today hi caleb is by the way love
your show watch it all the time thank
you uh I was wondering with all of the
YouTube d monetization stuff that's been
going on lately I understand that
segments of your radio show up here on
YouTube and you probably have a
partnership with you too before uh ads
that's correct but you also have private
you also private bad partnerships
correct for your radio show that is
indeed true uh I was wondering if I'm
your private add the partnerships had
any influence on the type of content
that you produced well listen I mean it
would sort I I believe that they don't
and I've never had an advertiser uh ever
tell me that the content on the show has
to be modified I've told the story of
were once i was approached by a chemical
company a very well known chemical
company and they were interested in
advertising because they had a new
progressive engagement initiative and
they wanted to reach more progressive
blah blah blah i just said no i mean
there's just there was no fit for it and
although we had never talked about that
company specifically uh we were we we
have for a long time in very critical of
this industry this is the same type of
industry where you end up seeing things
like the Teflon buy products that cause
cancer and so many other things and if I
it's only happened once or twice but if
I see a potential conflict we turn the
advertiser down our advertisers are you
know for example like Warby Parker which
makes glasses uh this is just nothing
that I could even imagine could at some
point uh be any kind of a conflict they
wouldn't even dream of telling us what
to do on the show so my view is the
content has not been influenced by
advertisers but you know I'm not in this
in the same way that I could critique
CNN and say even though they say they're
not influenced in some way without them
even knowing it they could be influenced
by ad
Kaiser's it's possible yet we really
have very few private advertisers uh and
and I have up I can say with with
significant certitude that it is not
playing any role in the content of the
show and you know what to go further
yesterday of our nine videos that we
uploaded for were initially not
monetized by YouTube I appealed all four
of those designations and fortunately
YouTube determined that those four
videos actually are eligible for
monetization their advertiser friendly
but my plan is to continue going forward
and unless it becomes a financial issue
and if that happened I would say to the
audience we need more members because
otherwise I've got to start focusing on
stories that will monetize I hope that
never happens by the way uh so far it is
not affecting our model okay great I
what I sound like I was accusing you of
anything else you're asking the exact
question you should be asking is a smart
media consumer which is hey if there are
advertisers I'd love to more know more
about that relationship and I'm
completely transparent in that and maybe
we'll do an even longer segment on it
thank you so much I really appreciate
the call we do have to move on with the
show that is going to do it for today
617 830 4750 is always the number for
phone calls and we will take more phone
call soon